this one took us eight years to get it
made so from a you know at first we
thought we couldn't make it for less
than like 35 million and and we were at
a studio and then it fell apart and then
we said okay well rebuild it for less
and then we rebuilt it for less and then
it fell apart again and then it fell
apart again and like actually once we
were about to leave the next day for
Thailand to shoot it we'd the actors
were you know on their way the you know
the locations were booked the crew was
booked and the day before we got on the
flight the plug got pulled and and it
was one of those like you know you know
suddenly you know the the next year's
worth of income just evaporates and you
just don't know what to do and it was
one of those dark dark moments and and
we ended up rebuilding it even smaller
and and got on a plane the next year but
you know well we'll never have goodbye
dinners like we kept doing good by
dinners and then not leaving and so yeah
we'll never do that again well and with
the casting there's some really
interesting things going on I mean you
have actors that are not primarily known
for but often known for comedy roles as
you know the couple and in Pierce
Brosnan who of course any time we see
him in the geopolitical setting it's
hard not to think of his days on her
majesty's secret service so that that
background gives you a little extra
something to play with doesn't it it
does it was fun playing with you know
people's preconceptions with that like
one of our touchstone films was
costa-gavras is missing which I just
think is one of the greatest movies ever
made and and you know the choice of like
Jack Lemmon in a situation like this
it's it's just such a different way to
see you know an event like that it
really it really makes it feel more real
somehow and to put Owen in this like
people kept asking us like are you going
to give them a crew-cut make him real
tough or like no we want the owen from
Marling and me in this situation and and
and it was great it was great like he's
so warm and like you really believe him
as a dad and it's really shocking when
you see him have to experience and even
you know partake in violence I'm glad
you didn't put the dog in it cuz people
who got mad yeah um speaking of
geopolitical things I mean
anytime we see Americans abroad in peril
and in settings that are horrific people
are going to look for messaging they're
going to add their own probably as well
does that make this an extra sensitive
venture or is that why you go in this
direction in the first place it does
it's interesting how you know I was
reading a like six months ago Serena
Capra's autobiography and he was saying
and this is like back in the 50s when he
was writing this and he was saying uh
you know it's hard to have a bad guy
who's not just insane because if you
have a bad guy that's a lawyer office
and all the lawyers get mad at you and
if you have a bet like and and I found
you know you know I found you know it
really interesting that you know if you
put a American family in a situation
abroad it's true like I've realized a
lot more people you know read into the
messaging of that or the you know people
you know I got a question a lot of you
know is it is it I don't know is it
insensitive to focus on an American
family in a foreign crisis but not the
people in the Christ you know around
them in the crisis and and you know I
keep thinking like you know and the
titanic in titanic like you're with Leo
and kate winslet but it doesn't mean you
don't care about everyone else but that
that you know there has to be a focus to
your movie and it's hard not to see the
world in an American perspective you
know being an American and an American
filmmaker especially if there's no
iceberg because then I mean that creates
a lot of frogs and as far as that with
did over that period of time since it
was a protracted period of time eight
years as you became more sensitive those
kinds of issues did the story change did
the characters change were there any
modulations as events in the real world
unfolded that may have had parallels
well it's interesting you know this you
know we wrote this initially before arab
spring before and and we used to have to
do a lot of exposition like you know
people read the script and say could
something like this really happen and
and and so we had a whole lot of
exposition early in the movie and then
Arabs
there was a fortunate like you know
thing in the Taj Mahal Hotel in India
and you know there's a whole series of
events that have happened where now you
know people you know people didn't
question and we were you know we took a
lot of the exposition back out because
it's a different world now where this
this seems a lot more possible and you
know with the children anytime there's
children in peril in a film I had a lot
of people are of the mind that there's
an extra responsibility for the
filmmakers to to make sure that they're
presenting this in a way that's
responsible or at least in tune what
they mean to say is that type of
conversations that you guys had and what
were some of the sensibilities that came
to bear on that a lot of you know we
really wanted did not to feel like like
icky that kids were there so we you know
we made a lot of efforts to make sure to
write you know when when Annie's
attacked we make sure to write them in a
place where they can't really see what's
happening and we cut back to see that we
that day you're not watching or you know
we you know we kept getting pressure
actually in in the development stage to
like you know two kids that's so much
money can't you just have one kid can't
you know can't you have a teenager you
know it's like no no like you know that
I mean that was that was a big challenge
for getting this thing made and we kept
saying like with two kids they can be
together you know with one kid they
always need to be in the mix with two
kids they can be together and be okay at
moments like you can actually spend you
know you can actually have them you know
they're more part of the story but
they're in a way they're less apart too
because they can sort of take care of
each other and enter or not you know you
know drew drew said sorry he couldn't be
here today but uh your brother my
brother and I wait you know co-write
together heat produced I directed and
and you know so where were you know
built in that duality mindset so it just
you know that made sense but there was a
lot of things that you know we wanted to
make sure that you don't get to the end
of the moving go like well great they
survived but those kids are you know
they're really going to be messed up
which they are you know I'm sure they'll
have some issues to deal in for sure
but you know he that was part of it you
know you know we got some pressure to
cut the hospital scene in the script
stage and we kept saying like that's
that's where you know they're going to
be okay like that's how you that's the
point that's the you know the reason you
know you know for us like you know sort
of going back to the political thing
trust like we really wanted this to be a
movie about a family and a movie about
getting through like you know all the
crazy obstacles you go through as a
family and you know the traumas and the
you know the things that that hopefully
bind you more together and you know
that's really you know that was our
focus originally we had a in the script
it was originally written as Cambodia is
the place are going and and we kept
getting the question like could this
happen in Cambodia like is the Khmer
Rouge still around is that like and we
started going like okay that's that's
not that's not the movie we're making
we're not we're not trying to make a
political statement on Cambodia or like
don't ever go to Cambodia you know we we
didn't want that to be the takeaway we
wanted you know we wanted to remain
focused on the family so we ended up
taking out you know the name or any
mention of the country you know in that
attempt and so and then one last thing
by doing that so by subtracting
political themes or messaging what is it
that you would circle just in a few
words maybe as being the the core
message or theme that you mentioned
family yeah that would be part of it
yeah i mean the connection of family and
that the you know there are those
moments where something crazy happens
and you know you get that phone call
like you know in middle the you know
middle of the day and something your
life is different and and you know I
really feel like at those moments like
you know when you bind together as a
family like we you know we had a you
know I guess 15 years ago now my dad got
in a plane crash and he's fine now he's
fine now but for it was really touch and
go he broke his skull in three places
and and I was living in LA and Drew's in
New York and you know everyone was there
in 12 hours we were all bedside and he
crashed in North Dakota and
we were suddenly like stuck in North
Dakota for six weeks like you know at
his bedside and it was amazing how
nothing like all these things I was
caught up in here and drew was caught up
like none of it mattered like you know
suddenly this was all that was important
and we you know we keep talking about
like how do you capture that how do you
capture that in film that that moment of
you know you're dealing with the noise
and the emails and all this stuff and
like suddenly it all drops away and
you're just there with your family and
so really we wanted to create that kind
of a you know that atmosphere in a
thriller